[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
so I might have to do it again today and
explain what
free speech is and what is protected is
speech
by the Constitution the ACLU Believe It
or Not does not know
what protected speech is
they have no clue they have no clue
that protected speech does not include
inciting violence nor does it include
anything that breaks terms of service of
a private company that's not protected
speech ACLU
now there are protected there is
protected speech
there is such a thing
but Facebook
ACLU is not let me repeat this
the Facebook the books the face
is not the government
it's not
the government
okay
it's it's just it's just not
and when you break the terms of service
that you agreed to
on a private platform
like Facebook or Twitter or YouTube
you can be taken off
if you break those terms of service now
Facebook has reinstated the Traders
account
I'm not I'm not against that okay I'm
not against Facebook or Twitter or
anyone else
letting us have the sunlight to
disinfect this vile [__] piece of
garbage because you know that I believe
that here
that sunlight is the best disinfectant
how do you think we stayed off the Red
Wave in 2022
we shine sunlight on exactly how they
want to destroy our democracy
and the country listened
and they they made action they engaged
in their democracy
by using the very thing that the
fascists are terrified of including
Trump
so him being on Twitter or Facebook
I really don't believe that it's bad
for the long term
now as far as protected speech goes it's
a totally another [__] issue
Facebook or Twitter
or whatever [__] private platform
that has a terms of service that you
agree to when you open an account on
their website
has the right to not let you post on
their website just like true social that
[__]
trash Heap over there
they have a terms of service you break
it they don't like you they can [__]
kick you off
it's just how it works
it's how it is so if you want your own
[__]
protected speech to be on the internet
without terms of service interfering in
your speech
then you have to I don't know open your
own website that's exactly what he did
Trump he opened fraud social of course
anything Trump touches turns to liquid
[__]
so it's an absolute trash Heap over
there so no one's paying attention to it
other than when he's absolutely telling
on himself and what crime he committed
confessing to his crimes in his post
oh there's a video over there today oh
we're gonna [__] watch it
it's I don't I don't know if you've been
uh paying attention here but we've been
watching the M M's
Saga with Nick Adams in these videos
these [__] these what have to be
they have to be satire and parody
there's no way this [__] is real It's
gotta be comedy like Gabe Sanchez said
he I think Nick Adams is actually Andy
Kaufman
but this video from Donald Trump oh my
God it is [__] hilarious it is
hilarious that whiny little [__]
[__]
sets up a camera
and screams Ray Epps into the [__]
Minecraft I'm not [__] you screams
of raps as if that's gonna change the
hearts and minds of Jack Smith and the
special counsel
he's in big trouble with collusion too
big trouble
I believe that the documents case not
only did he steal documents
to cover up his coup attempt but he
stole documents and intelligence that
shows that there was collusion with
Russia hmm seems seems kind of funny
since we have I don't know
the guy at the FBI
who not only not only did he say before
the 2016 ah there's no collusion here
there's no collusion
but now we find out that he took
counterintelligence Adam Mueller
the Mueller report and the Mueller
investigation that special counsel
took counterintelligence totally out of
the investigation totally off the table
same [__] that was taking money
from oligarapotska
a [__] Russian oligarch Putin's
little [__] suck toy
that's how this works folks
look they yell and he says deep state in
this video that we're gonna watch he
yells at Deep State deep State raps deep
State no collusion
look he's obsessed that with the 2020
election because he lost by 8 million
but he's still [__] obsessed with the
2016 election that he lost by 3 million
he just ended up on a technicality being
the leader of the Free World and he
[__] that up
royally
but he's definitely
was for sure and still is Putin's puppet
and I don't know if you uh caught it
yesterday but Joe Biden is going to give
a battalion of Tanks
to Ukraine to make sure that they can
kick Russia's ass
it's enough for this [__] dictator
murderous War crime [__] trying
to take over Sovereign democracies and
bang up the rest of democracy around the
world it's enough of that [__]
us as democracy should not put up with
that [__]
not for one [__] second
so the fact that we're showing strength
for democracy by Def letting Ukraine
defend theirs and making sure they have
the proper equipment
to [__] smash the Russian army
and knock Putin back into the last
century where he was with the KGB
and get this murders dictator off
democracy's ass
thank you
but of course the [__] fascists in
this country Putin's puppets Trump
included they think it's a horrible idea
that the United States give tanks
to defend democracy around the world
they
don't want democracy
I don't know if you figure that out that
that that's why they [__] that's why
they [__] love Putin
Putin is willing to go to war
with democracy he's willing to smash
Sovereign democracies
and they love it
they [__] love it democracy is their
enemy
said that time and time again democracy
is their enemy why do you think Trump is
so terrified that he's making videos
screaming rats and deep State into a
microphone
listen
intent and obstruction intent and
obstruction intent and obstruction keep
repeating it
intent and obstruction intent and
obstruction keep repeating it
he's showing us his intent folks he
always does
he always tells on himself
he can't help it
he can't help but take the thing he's
guilty of
and make sure to get ahead of the
narrative so that his [__] followers
will will yell and scream some [__]
into the comment section on Facebook now
yesterday there was news that uh several
of the documents that were marked top
secret
that ended up at Mar-A-Lago are not
going to be part of the investigation
now a lot of people might freak out
about that
but it only tells me one thing
there are targets of this investigation
their targets
they know the information that was
stolen they know the intent and they
know why there was obstruction
they know
that's why they're not going to waste
much time
with documents
and trying to uncover rocks that have no
[__] no treasure underneath them
of sniffing out and exposing charging
and Prosecuting these crimes
of seditious conspiracy
of obstructing official proceeding
who knows what kind of financial Crimes
of the Super PAC
and taking money from [__] Russian
oligarchs
the FBI agent hey hey everybody I I
don't know if you you know this the FBI
agent
who is in charge of counterintelligence
who said before the 2000 oh there's no
obstruction no collusion
and took counterintelligence out off the
table for Mueller to investigate ow he
was taking Russian money
from darapaska
and you want to know who the [__]
deep state is
you want to know where the conspiracy
theories lie you do not have to look far
you do not have to look far you only
have to go to Donald Trump's statements
and and his Allied statements
they're telling on themselves it's very
simple very easy
and they're losing the plot
I mean it's slipping away fast quick and
in a hurry especially when Donald Trump
thanks Jim Jordan in this [__] video
thanks Jim Jordan
I don't know if you know what kind of
[__] scumbag Jim Jordan is Jim I
don't repent Port sex crimes Jordan
but him and Matt gatz are in a [__]
competition who is the scummiest piece
of [__]
in the House of Representatives
and Trump wants to thank him you know
for lying for him
spreading his lies
spreading the misinformation I loves
that
Jim Jordan of course this morning on
Twitter
and we might get to all this I'm just
giving you the [__] facts I'm just
laying it out for you Jim Jordan's
really excited that Trump's back on
Facebook this morning oh he's really
excited and not only that Jim Jordan is
probably going to start some sort of
[__] fraud scam committee summons
fraud investigation into Facebook a why
the government the government
can force Facebook
to put the fascist on Facebook
and cancel everyone else I'm sure that
is the committee that he's going to have
you know government interference like
they [__] about with Elon and [__]
Trump on Twitter files how the
government the government interfered the
government took over Twitter
they literally
they literally are gonna say by the end
of the day
the Republican house should investigate
Facebook and take it over and make sure
that we tell them who they can and who
they can't have on their platform the
government
you know this is something that they do
really well
in this country the fascist that is the
Republicans and they've done it for
decades and decades and decades very
well
and liberals suck at it they [__]
suck we suck at this I mean some of us
not me I don't suck at this
but liberals in general are [__]
horrible at this
they're looking at this situation with
this with the Facebook just in this
issue alone
and they're going to be like oh it's so
dangerous that Donald Trump is back on
[__] Facebook oh my God what are we
gonna do he's gonna steal away our
[__] rights by being on faith this is
the dumbest [__] I've ever heard in my
life
you you you as a citizen and as a
pro-democracy soldier out there because
that's what we are right now folks and
we have to use our ballots as our
weapons to defend our democracy
our right to vote if we don't use it
we'll lose it I'm telling you and we
used it in 2022 thank you very much a
big thank you to democracy all around
the world that you used your weapon of
the ballot to defend democracy
who gives a flying rat's ass if Trump
can post on Facebook our true social or
or someone else put out the statement on
Twitter
who gives a flying rat's [__] ass
what platform it's on
you are the power
you are the ones who decide not [__]
Facebook
not some bot farm from Russia spreading
around misinformation on Facebook it's
you you are the messaging you are the
narrative you are real people you are
eyeballs and ears human beings ballots
votes
don't forget that
just because they're gonna fake some
support on Facebook and spread around a
bunch of [__] to the to the lowest
common denominator in this country you
think that can stop us
you think that can stop the
pro-democracy Coalition we fended off a
red wave a historical
red wave that was supposed to happen
that always happens oh my God it always
happens
it's a thing that's a you remember the
media oh must be real oh my God they're
spreading all around social media they
shared it on Twitter it must be real get
the [__] out of here with that goddamn
nonsense
Donald Trump being on Twitter or
Facebook or wherever the [__] is not
dangerous folks it's not get over it let
me tell you what is [__] dangerous
when you when you give up
and don't fight back against these
[__] fascists that's dangerous that's
the danger we face
is being complicit
is not forming a narrative and a
national message
that's the danger here to democracy
we are going to listen listen to me when
I tell you this
we are going to save democracy with our
messaging and our narrative
it will drive votes
it will drive people to the polls
in 2024
and we have to start now because I don't
know if you noticed
but the America First Nazi party is not
going to wait until next year to start
bashing up our democracy I don't know if
you're paying attention or not
the good news is we have almost two full
years folks
to form a national narrative in National
messaging to beat back the America First
Nazi party
foreign
we got we got plenty of time
and plenty of space
and let me tell you oh buddy are they
gonna give us
plenty plenty of soil to plant the seed
of our messaging in this country just
like they did in 2022 when they were
cheering not just cheering but leaning
in to taking away women's rights
leaning into it I mean they were like
yeah full on [__] it we're not even
gonna we're not just gonna try to strip
it away from you in each one of these
states
we want a National Abortion ban we want
to tell women what they can and can't
wear in the Missouri legislature they
can show their arms or not we want to
tell women what the [__] they can and
what they can't do and this country went
whoa whoa wait a second
no no you ain't gonna tell us what the
[__] to do
you ain't gonna tell us what the [__] to
do in Kansas
in several other states
they voted down
voted down on referendums the ability
for their state legislators to take away
women's rights in their states
liberalism is a funny thing
a lot of people don't want to identify
as a liberal because they're they're
they don't know what it is they haven't
looked it up yet
go look up the word liberal go look it
up
and when you get done reading it
trying to argue with anyone
that liberalism is not for real [__]
freedom and liberty
because the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
so go look the word up
put the definition to half your memory
and then try to argue with someone that
liberalism isn't for freedom
the one trouble that they have
the thing that stands in their way
of doing what they want to our country
and to your way of life
is liberalism it's liberty
it's the idea of equity and equality for
all through democracy it's tough It's a
[__] democracy look I'm not I'm
not going to sit here and [__] you
democracy is a [__] it is tough
ass work it takes a long time to move
the needle in democracy it really truly
does
it is the hard work that Society has to
do
on behalf of the future
of that Society
because the things that we do now
the things that we work hard for now may
not bear fruit for us that are here
in this democracy
but it will bear fruit for the future
it will ensure
that for decades to come that fascism
will not rear its ugly [__] head
again in this country that it can crawl
back underneath its [__] rock where
it belongs because you can't kill an
idea
you're not going to kill fascism the
idea of it the ideology there's always
going to be [__] scumbag Nazis always
we just need to get them to crawl back
underneath that little fascist rock that
they were hiding under for a long time
well and
and not be so avert
overtly uh Nazis right I mean come on
conservatism has been thin veiled
fascism in this country for [__] 50
years give me a break especially ramping
it up in the 1980s when they leaned into
religious conservatism fascism
it's thin veil [__] fascism folks
when someone says I'm a conservative or
I'm a religious conservative
I'm a republican because I'm
conservative you're not conservative
you you think you are because your daddy
and your daddy's daddy said he was
conservative and Republican you don't
know what the [__] conservative means
when you say it
conservative they want to I don't know
conserve the status quo not move the
needle forward
conservatives don't want to move the
needle backwards
that's not the definition of
conservative
that's not what a conservative in the
ideology would want to do
[__] boneheads is what they are and
they're they're fascist
they're fascist
Nazis
and don't be afraid to call them that
to their face
it makes them well listen when you call
a fascist a fascist to their DK get
really [__] pissed off oh my God you
there is one easy way to offend a real
fascist
is calling that oh they get [__]
pissed
they really get [__] pissed all kinds
of [__]
all kinds of hot when you call fascist a
fascist
I've been called the fascist to my face
and I was not offended because I know
what fascism is and I know what Liberty
is and I know what liberalism is and
liberalism is not fascism
liberalism is not weak
liberalism is the strength of people
the strength of decency
the strength to move equity and equality
forward no matter how slow or how hard
it may be
because it is and again I'm not going to
[__] you
democracy is difficult it is a
[__]
you look at Ukraine
their democracy has been corrupt since
since its Inception
but they're still willing to die for it
to die for even maybe the hint of a
little bit of Liberty
and a little bit of liberalism
and it breeds strength
and it breeds decency
foreign
as Donald Trump makes his way back onto
these platforms stop your [__]
whining and crying
stop
being such a goddamn snowflake
stand up use your voice use the
messaging use the narrative to push back
that's what we will do
that's how we will win
that is how fascism in this country in
the Maga movement
the America First Nazi parties trumpism
America Fat American fascism will be
beat back underneath its [__] rock
where it belongs
in the fringes of society hidden away
with the lowest common denominators and
the lowest percentage of support
that is how
sunlight is the best disinfectant but
you must
you must be the sunlight
you must be the beams of democracy you
you are the key
remember that going forward into the
2024 election and I'll keep saying it
over and over and over and over again
because it ain't Facebook that's gonna
win the 2024 election it ain't Twitter
that's gonna win the 2024 election I
don't care how many retweets you get I
don't care how many times you [__]
like that son of a [__] I don't care
how many times you put it in a DM room
to be shared around and spread around
what ratio you get on what [__] tweet
or what [__] Facebook post or
Instagram whatever the [__] it is
the thing that will stop fashion fascism
in this country is for you to engage
into your democracy in a real way with
your ballot
that is the thing that they are
terrified of is you voting and they're
also terrified of you listening here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch two full
hours do not forget to subscribe to the
YouTube channel if you're not on YouTube
right now head on over to YouTube go to
the Tony Michaels podcast hit subscribe
if you're here now and you're not
subscribed I don't know what the hell
you're doing
how many days have you been sitting here
watching and you're not subscribed holy
[__]
make sure to also download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google make
sure to subscribe and leave us a great
comment and a great review while you're
there on that platform and if you're on
Facebook might just touch Facebook page
come on over to our Facebook page at the
Tony Michaels you can watch the show
there you can also see some clips we're
gonna bring you some clips and great
memes why not
and also twitch is free did you know
that twitch is free you can download the
app a lot of people like the chat over
on Twitch it's a little different
streaming software than YouTube
but do me a favor no matter what
platform you like to watch no matter
what where you like to listen to the
Tony Michaels podcast please please
please
go subscribe to the YouTube channel and
share it with three friends share this
link
Today's Show just tell them listen to
the first 30 minutes
just listen to the first 30 minutes
Tony's not scared of trump being on
Facebook or Twitter what's this Liberals
are not scared of trump being on
on face I am not scared of trump being
that is ridiculous that we should be
terrified and that we're in danger if
Trump is on Facebook or Twitter that's
[__] absolutely asinine it is up to
us it is a danger if we let it be a
danger folks
it's us we are in the fight it is our
democracy it is our government
and we will fight for the future with
our ballot that's what we will do oh
also I want to thank everyone again I'm
trying to figure out exactly how I want
to do these shout outs for the people
who have uh subscribed to patreon uh you
can go to the tonymichaels.com and you
can see the patreon link there or you
can go to patreon.com the Tony Michaels
I think the moderators put it in the
chat and you can support me on patreon I
appreciate all the support uh wow we
we've only mentioned it I think twice
here on the show
and we've gotten dozens of members
already
I'm very excited about the patreon and
I'm very excited to figure out exactly
how I want to do your shout outs but I
want to tell you as a group of people
thank you no matter if you got the shout
out or not thank you for coming and
supporting me on patreon it means the
world to me you are the best audience in
the world with the best moderators
please give them support wherever you're
chatting whatever social media platform
you're on right now and don't go
anywhere no don't go anywhere I got a
few things I want to show you in the
shitless Roundup when we round up the
Tweety tweets and trendy Trends stick
around we'll be right back right after
this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
okay I kind of went off on a tangent
there oh wait that
um every day
I forgot to uh explain to the ACLU
what the [__] protected speeches
[Music]
because as much as I don't give two
[__] shits if Facebook or Twitter or
whatever social media platform want to
have that [__] vile Trader on their
platform whatever they want to do
whatever the [__] they want to do it's
their [__] blant form we should not
be scared of this like I said really
honestly what you should do is go over
on that platform if you have an account
and fight back get your voice heard
against it form the national narrative
and the national messaging hey guess
what it's going to be right here on the
Tony Michaels podcast
all the way up to the 2024 election and
Beyond I'm not going to stop
I won't I'm not going to that's why I
appreciate your support on patreon keeps
me talking keeps me going
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels or go
to thetonymichaels.com
thetonymichaels.com we'll link for the
patreon is at the top
it's a five ten or twenty dollars
there's also
I figured I'd get around here maybe
someone will do it I doubt it but maybe
someone will do it just just click on
the um view all uh the tears and there's
a fifty thousand dollar tier so if you
want me to shut up for a full month I'll
shut up for a full month but it's gonna
cost you it's gonna cost you fifty
thousand dollars I don't know maybe I
can be bought I doubt that anyone's
gonna gonna buy it we'll see and you
know what I would do I would just stop
talking and I'd have someone take over
the show for a month for me that's what
I would do anyway that's probably what I
do may I give him half of it let them um
let them take over the show for a month
then I'm not talking it's just them I
just go dark for a month let them talk
here on the show
maybe you'll get Rachel bittick offer
come on
and give you the national narrative in
National messaging
that's what we have to do folks we
cannot be afraid
of these scumbags we cannot be afraid of
these file Traders and we watched
yesterday as Adam Schiff and Eric
swalwell
and Omar was stripped of their
committees
and and the reason why is because Kevin
McCarthy is weak
he's [__] weak
he's terrified of them he's terrified of
Adam Schiff and Eric swalwell
terrified uh and more Adam ship news by
the way he is going to be running for
the United States Senate seat at this
point it's him and Katie Porter
I don't know who I would throw my
support behind at this point
um doesn't really matter folks which one
wins I I know Katie and Adam Shipp will
will have a classy Primary in in
California
and they're going to try to win the
votes just like they should in democracy
and and may the best candidate win but
may we support the candidate whoever
comes out of that primary especially and
there might be a few more that work
their way into this primary race but the
two highlights at this point is Katie
Porter Adam Schiff and then Katie
Porter's whiteboard I don't know if
Katie Porter's whiteboard is running
separately from Katy border I'm not
really sure yet
we'll find out uh soon so and that's
some news and the only the only reason
why the the entry of some of these uh
candidates for the United States Senate
seat and rather it be Feinstein seat in
California and uh
Dianne Feinstein is probably not going
to run I guess apparently this morning
or her teen said that she won't announce
until into 2024. uh meaning she's gonna
let these primaries play out a little
bit
and she's probably not gonna probably
not gonna stand in their way because
she's she would get beat it's the last
thing a politician how they want to
retire is get beat in a primary
by a formidable opponent like either
Adam Schiff or Katie Porter which both
are are very formidable opponents
and and they're both
uh carriers of democracy Adam Schiff and
Katie Porter both and I I wish them both
the best of luck in that primary
but we should not as pro-democracy
people be focusing our national
narrative on that primary
so that is all you need to know about it
that's it we don't even know anything
else about it unless you're in
California you're voting for them you
don't even know anything yeah I need to
[__] worry about that race
that primary seat will get seated
and California will do the thing they do
and go vote
but the national narrative is is a more
important Endeavor here
but being as it is that these races are
starting early that's part of the
national narrative
folks we have to get out ahead of these
fascists
now like Lucas Koontz
in Missouri Lucas is going to run in the
primary
for the Democratic seat
the ticket excuse me the Democratic
ticket
to face off against Josh Hawley
which
in any other timeline in any other point
in history uh Josh Hawley should be one
of the easiest sitting Senators to beat
he doesn't even live in this state
that's right Josh Hawley doesn't even
live in bucking Missouri
should be one of the easiest defeats
that carpet bag and son of a [__] that
[__] insurrectionist that scared
little [__] running away from the
rioters that he incited
[__] coward
so we will find out and also and looks
like people are going to enter the race
in Arizona but it's significant that
these Democrats are ending the race
first
that they're making moves for these
races and the reason why is because they
know they know
what they're up against it is not gonna
it's not gonna be all sunshine and
rainbows
for shift and and Katie Porter out in
California no matter which one wins the
primary it's not going to be all
sunshine and rainbows
I don't know if you notice
but the American first Nazi party is
Relentless in their effort to destroy
our democracy
and it doesn't matter if it's our
federal government or our state
governments our County or our school
boards they are helmet on destroying
democracy everywhere in any every corner
of our country Jesus Christ Ron DeSantis
is Banning College Prep African-American
studies an elective College course for
17 and 18 year olds elective you don't
have to take this [__] and then on top
of that he's Banning classroom libraries
they were like oh no we just want to
make sure that there's a few books that
aren't in front of children that we're
not Banning books we're not burning
books that's not what we're doing
hey you're gonna get there right Gabe
Sanchez they're gonna get there soon
that starts I don't know it is how it
starts maybe maybe they they're gonna
take the history book and ban that one
too about uh 1930s and 1940s Germany
about how they um you sure they're gonna
you shouldn't were you saying they're
gonna keep it or they're gonna take it
no they're gonna get rid of that they
don't want people to know what happens
when they start Banning libraries and
[__] right right they don't want to see
those those photos of Joseph Goebbels
and the rest of those [__] Nazis
perfect books right right now well
absolutely absolutely I bet you they I
bet you they love that book Fahrenheit
451.
they they don't like to read is the is
the issue they don't want any and they
just I bet you they don't even
understand what for what what 451
degrees Fahrenheit even means probably
probably not probably not I want to go
to the shitless Roundup here because
I've got we've got a lot of stuff to get
to but
um
oh and I I hate to do this but we've
gotta we've gotta go to True social
today in the [__] list Roundup well pack
your bags people
social now I I honestly maybe this is
the reason why I can't wait for this guy
to get over to everyone's so [__]
scared of him being on Twitter and
Facebook right they're so fine now the
ACLU I don't know if you've seen this
this morning but they got protected
speech all wrong
um which is surprising from the ACLU you
would think the ACLU of all [__]
organizations would have protective
speech
correct but they do not have it correct
and I was gonna talk about that in the
first 30 minutes I got off track yeah we
get off track I all the time you ever
see me get off track
all the time every day every day yeah I
just want to I just want to give a shout
out to the people who are in the
comments I am very happy that everyone
knows uh that 451 degrees uh the
temperature that paper burns at so I'm
glad that you know if if we're comparing
you know a group that knows their [__]
versus a group that doesn't because
we're about to visit that group on true
social I just want to say
so so yeah so what you're saying is what
you're saying is you're glad that they
know how hot it has to be to actually
burn a book I'm glad that the people who
are watching are smart enough to know
that but I guarantee if you ask anyone
on the Republican side you're like hey
what is 451 degrees Fahrenheit mean uh
they'd probably be like in that in that
that movie Michael Moore made and that
that movie Fahrenheit yeah yeah yeah
here tonight 451 there was also the
actual movie Fahrenheit 451 with I think
it was
um Michael Shannon and Michael B Jordan
I think it was oh okay yeah yeah yeah
but it's about it's just it's just the
book in a movie form oh do they burn the
movie or burn the book does how how hot
does it have to be to burn the movie
that's a good question
and we're supposed to 92 degrees I
thought we're supposed to know these
things Gabe Sanchez yeah you know I mean
sometimes I just make sure someone well
I think I think you make a lot of [__]
up but I mean
you say what's the temperature to burn a
DVD part of me is like none because you
do it on your computer oh boom boom
that's a dirty joke that's a dated joke
oh listen any kids that are listening
burning DVDs there's a thing
see lab laptops used to have a disc in
it like yeah you had to put crazy there
was a whole slot you put it in you know
it just came out you put the disc in you
put it back in and it went and it turns
it like it doesn't actually damage him
yeah but it's good
uh yep yep that's I don't know the I
don't I know the temperature which you
oh you know you know what I know what
burns that but you have no [__] idea
what a CD burns out dude
this should be common knowledge it
should be we got to start burning DVDs
like we should just have a list of [__]
and at what temperature Fahrenheit they
they
um you know combusted I'm just saying
now we are gonna go over to true I don't
want to warn the audience do not go away
you're not gonna want to miss this I'm
telling you now we watched the Nick
Adams video where he pantsless the other
day and he's talking about how he won
the m m fight which they [__] yeah
they hooked line sink baited that dumb
[__] but this video from Trump is way
better he yells right some deep State
into a microphone now I want to warn the
audience this [__] is like four
or five minutes long and it's hilarious
it is [__] I have now watched
oh it's funnier than [__] it's funnier
and [__] I don't know how many takes it
took him to do this five minute video
but God damn are there multiple angles
um you know I I was listening to it
honestly I didn't watch it much I was
just listening and you're a true fan
yeah yeah true fan of Trump no I I saw a
clip of the video here coach D has it
let's do this let's do this let's do
this we need to round up the Tweety
tweets and Trends on the shitless
Roundup and we are going to get into
some deep [__] today because we are
going to the Deep State fraud social
website
um to look at the Cheeto dusk you and
honors
fraud social feed so let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
the [__] list
Roundup boy are we gonna round up a lot
of [__] today
um with this um
a journey over to fraud social but
listen I tell you folks that we don't
really pay attention much to his feed
unless it's significant and I think
there's significant points in this video
not only that it's [__] hilarious uh
that this guy is making this content uh
he's terrified he's a corner trap little
animal and it's only going to get better
when he comes on Twitter and Facebook
it's only going to get better like
that's what they're doing is practicing
because he was making videos with like a
cell phone in his office next to the Kim
Jong-un picture but now that he now that
he's running and he has to appear to
have a legitimate campaign he's got to
do a little higher quote higher
production value I mean this is what the
donations are paying for you know well
yeah
it's not it's not paying for everything
else that this this guy does but here
here's what led me to know that he had a
video up
coach D had it here he said uh let me
help you Ray Epps was an idiot who went
to the Capitol on January 6 because he
believed that a stolen election lie he's
not FBI he's not CIA he's just another
Mega [__]
and this is just seven seconds of it and
I was like whoa whoa wait a second hold
the phone you mean Grandpa made a new
video I gotta go watch this [__] and I
went immediately after watching this
clip
to the Five Minute actual video because
it's totally worth it
um but watch this clip this is [__]
hilarious on January 6 and who is raps
tell me about raps where does he come
from I think we know
what uh
generation raps who's rats rats and rips
Joe Biden I mean it just uh these
[__] these [__] all these
ding-a-lings man where does he come from
I think we know what does that even mean
yeah I don't like we're hit I don't know
like where his home his I he he had a
mom I'm sure yeah you know he's in a
womb at some point I mean what do they
think he's an alien
like like an outer space question I
don't know you know I think I mean just
like some sort of AI or a robot well I
don't understand I mean anyone any
anyone that is potentially working
against Trump is
you know they're like this guy don't
know if he's real could be fake could be
an alien could be about a snatcher don't
know
oh my God
okay well here we go let's um let's go
to the um let's go to full version here
um and you can't find the full version
uh other than
true social this is why I'm excited from
the [__]
misinformation teat itself right well
this is why I'm excited actually about
him just going to Facebook and Twitter
so that way I can just finally delete
the true social app off my phone do you
think that people are gonna do you think
that the people that swore themselves
had never return to Twitter because
Trump was banned and had to go to gab
get her
uh Rumble uh uh parlor truth social do
you think those people are going to come
back do I think those people are liars
yes the answer okay yes yes I do think
that I mean this is all an exercise of
stupidity really because yeah the left
you know what this is the this is the
[__] this is the [__] Eminem thing
this is the Eminem thing all over again
because Liberals are like oh my God it's
such a danger that he's gonna be on
Twitter and I'm like look man what what
do you think he's doing over there he's
doing the same [__] over there well more
people will see it yeah well it what we
have to do as pro-democracy Coalition is
make sure more people hear the rebuttal
to his dumbass [__] comments like
sunlight truly is the best disinfectant
but we
our narrative has to be the sunlight to
disinfect it like you can't just let it
be out there in the open you head my
only issue with him on Facebook you're
going to push back on me yeah I I only
like I don't care about Twitter social
whatever my only concern with Facebook
yeah is the the reach of advertising
that you can accomplish through Facebook
and we've seen it I mean like let's go
all the way back to uh uh right right
okay you still millions of of data
points about people use that
successfully for your own campaign and
then after that right like Facebook it's
be look I'll just say what it is
Facebook is a pile pile of steaming [__]
okay it's not good I haven't been there
you're on Facebook you're on that
steaming pile of garbage right now
broadcasting live from the steaming pile
of garbage I'm sorry my personal opinion
I'm not on it I left Facebook over a
year ago I was like yeah but you yeah
but you you
yeah whether they want to share it over
there that's fine but look at the end of
the day
it's become
I don't know what happened it broke it
broke oh my God we we we saved one bad
thing about Facebook and it we say one
bad thing about Facebook and it breaks
honestly dude it's like dude Zuck get
off my nuts bro Mark Mark really come on
man this is what I get last night last
night I was in the car and I was
Mark I I'm debating now in my mind
whether I leave the Blank Spot in the
audio version
um I I'm not sure if I put like a sound
in there that's like right technical
difficulties because you know the sound
version's a little different when
someone's listening to it and there's a
big space the way you want to see it
you're like what the hell happened but I
I have no idea what just happened they
kicked us out of this dude Mark
Zuckerberg's like oh oh we'll kick you
want to yeah oh
oh no is he doing it again can everyone
still see me is it just for Tony
people people send up a test a test he
just having none of it he's having it
what's going on I have no idea it's so
weird Mark Zuckerberg is pissed off all
I'm saying is last night I was in the
car and I was listening to the radio and
creep came on and I immediately thought
hey I should go home and watch The
Social Network so last night I went home
and I started watching The Social
Network and here I am [__] on The
Social Network wait a second wait a
second wait a second so not only not
only does Facebook I'm sure they know
this that yeah we're knocking on them
because we're live on Facebook and you
watch this the the the the the the this
movie about the Facebook and Mark
Zuckerberg and now Mark you think he's
like sitting there and he's just like
hitting the button here I think I think
he's waiting every time we say something
bad about it he's like see you see you
see ya and I I honestly don't know
what's going on something just happened
twice it cut us off now it doesn't cut
the broadcast it just cuts us out of the
broadcast
could see a live stream the way we it
works through our live stream is the
feed will stay open yeah because it's
it's not it's not local it's often a
cloud somewhere it's off in the Deep
State Cloud the joros George Soros deep
State cloud and George Santos deep State
Cloud oh is it George Santos Cloud now
I'm just saying wait that is a that's a
damn good question is George Santos
actually George Soros
we should ask him that question I bet he
would have a very unique answer oh I'm
I'm sure I am sure
ah well let's see if we can get our
broadcast back together here and see if
I won't say anything bad Zuck okay calm
the [__] well I know it's not on my end
because it's not on my end because it
kicks both of us out yeah so when we
kicks both of us out it's something
happening internally and Mark Zuckerberg
is is I think he's intentionally he's
hacked in and now he's like
everyone make sure that if you're on the
broadcast right now if you're listening
make sure that if we somehow get cut off
that we will be back some shape or some
form and we might have to start a new
link just stay right here this show
didn't Jeffrey Epstein himself okay
that's speaking of conspiracy theories
here is a grandpa poopy pants
um in this video this is the full I
think it's almost like five minutes and
yeah I really truly do want to launch
all five minutes on the show it's gonna
give us almost like 45 minutes worth of
content because this guy is a [__]
[__] he is such a dumbass oh my God
he's such an idiot
um and of course the reason why I
changed his name Gabe Sanchez from the
the Cheeto dust mobster because that's
that's what I I called him for a long
time I change it to the Cheeto dust Q
anoner you're going to experience why it
was very vital and important that I
change his name from the Cheeto dust
mobster to the Cheeto dust Q anoner when
we get into the
um the theories of this video now the
ending is beautiful that's why I want to
play the whole thing because of who he
thinks he thinks it's a good idea but
let's let's watch the new house
committee on the weaponization of the
federal government is a rare chance to
expose the breathtaking corruption of
the security State the media and the
Washington swamp
here okay first off the name of the
committee is absolute Brilliance and
projection because literally what
they're going to do with this committee
is they're going to use their government
power to try to force private entities
to do [__] that they don't want to do
which is what they claim in the Twitter
files I don't know how many hundreds of
Twitter filed things they have now but
that's what they write on on at least 1
312. and he makes he makes them really
really odd some really cool Santos likes
false claims towards the Twitter files
and Twitter here yeah
um in this thing oh you're gonna love
them you're gonna love them yeah I I
mean and I I have to tell you that I
don't even know if George Santos could
come up with these [__] lies this is
it's gonna be incredible well because
I've said before Donald Trump is the OG
Santos right right right he's the
Original Gangster here man maybe maybe
he's thinking maybe he's thinking yeah
Santos is getting all the [__]
Felicity oh I see what's going on so
he's like hey man we really yeah I gotta
I gotta out Santo Santos right right
which is
I kind of I kind of want to see Santos I
mean like Santos is definitely he the
other day he was like oh I've been
enshrined in late night television
history it's like nah dude you're
[__] buried you're the punch wander
yeah dude you were making fun of on
multiple late late night shows everybody
laughed at you and with those those late
night shows uh so now you know now it
comes down to how you plan to use the
word Santos as a verb he's got Santos uh
don't be Santos in me right now you know
like she's like yeah well uh Gary B from
on YouTube he makes a good point Trump
and Santos lie off that would be you
know they had like the dance offs and
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that
would be pretty cool to watch you know
what I mean like that would be some good
[__] content to mock right and I'm
not saying that they'd have to get
together like literally yeah you know
live from the depths of Hell we've got
in this corner George Santos always
least we think it is Donald Trump ding
ding ding ladies and gentlemen oh let's
get ready to lie I I think I'm I'm
probably that's probably trademarked by
Michael Buffer I probably can't say that
can I uh no you could say everything
let's get ready to and then say the the
r word yeah yeah because he actually has
that trademark right yeah the smartest
move he's the [__] richest [__] oh
yeah because he's the only one that
cashes checks him and his son you know
it's you know his son does it too yeah
yeah you might as well if that's what
you're making the money well I think
those are the only two
um two people that can actually go you
know because he has permission he owns
it and then he gave his son permission
it's it's a business they just that's
what if you were to be like let's get
ready to stumble you know that's pretty
good I don't know we may we may have
problem in court with the St and the r
but it's not that it's not enough I'm
not sure what the threshold is for the
trademark but okay
um speaking of um trademarked this guy
looks like he's got some trademarks on
his face I want to point this out again
he really is trying on the production
here right like yeah I mean they look
better than the yellow wall one
Mar-A-Lago all right well I mean this is
Admiral no no totally this is I mean
this is this is this isn't green screen
right you don't think this is green no
no in the same room that he did those
interviews for that one documentary on
Discovery Plus
bring the cup back no no remove the
table
okay and can you take that thing off the
cup I think can you make me less orange
yeah can you make me less orange I know
my makeup is very orange but can you
make me less just just desaturate no
like I'm sorry sir this is uh this is as
good as again this is how it's gonna be
well let's
let's see is as good as this gets it
gets worse every single second but let's
keep going here here are just a few of
the questions the committee hopefully
will be asking
number one who is on the Mueller Witch
Hunt
that investigated me
and ordered dozens and dozens of cell
phones to be wiped clear of all data
after the phones were requested by the
office of the Inspector General who by
the way did a fantastic report on the
corrupt
FBI
and did you catch the question yet I
didn't I haven't caught the question
he's gone on to say corrupt FBI but also
the Inspector General did a good job
and people are scared of this guy being
back on Facebook are you [__] kidding
me why don't you get it once you get to
the question then I'll I'll assess
whether this guy is ready to be uh
president again it it would be hilarious
to watch Jim Jordan
like hold like take this script
it's quote script and just say these
questions
to I I I don't know who the [__] he's
gonna ask these questions to but just
just ask these questions to I don't know
clouds just yell them at the clouds and
see what pops out
what what the okay let's see if there's
a question mark anywhere in this
rambling corrupt Comey and all of the
rest of them but they asked it all data
on their phones never done this before
we wiped off
in some cases they said oh I'm sorry it
was a mistake can you imagine what we
would have found
what do you mean like the Secret Service
and struck
and all of them all of them there was
almost a question mark there there was
it was awesome
he's almost he's bringing up he's
bringing up cell phones and I'm and you
know just oh just happens to be a
coincidence again
ask the question why did the Secret
Service wipe their phones of the
information that we as the country
needed to know about this comeback
trying to commit a coup on January 6th
why after why the Watchdog group was
like hey can we get those cell phones
right why did they wipe those messages
that's a question mark That's how you
asked a question but this guy keeps
going on and on and on rambling usually
a question like
it's like like it it goes up and right
yeah right like right there there's
there's an inflection for a question I
mean you don't have to have an
inflection right like if you're right
that's a good like it's a good idea
signal for most people right like when
you're communicating with people it's a
good it's a penetrator
hey that's
that question maybe Jim Jordan Matt Getz
Donald Trump should ask themselves I
don't know I'm just saying I want to go
back to this cut here did you notice
this cut I don't know who's editing this
for him it's like they hired him like a
five dollar like a five dollar fiber
editor screen shutter
are you saving this for a thumbnail I
should
say I gotta get it you gotta get it
[Applause]
[Music]
got it perfect thumbnail okay watch the
cut here watch the transition and and I
my guess is and you you can tell me but
my guess is is that he did this five
minute rant like 16 different times yeah
and then they just kind of like took the
best of what they had to work with and
kind of I'm sure they gave him breaks to
be like all right we're gonna break here
right let's change your diaper let's
change your diaper and then we'll go
back
okay watch this cut from one position to
the other and even the audio watch this
this is great
and all of them all of them who in the
Mueller team was in charge of leaking
Secrets all of them all of them why did
they keep that in the cut I don't know I
mean at least
at least this one
is the same color
as the other one the other the other
time when we watched it it was there was
like a yellow hint to it right so the
editor the editor must have been
watching your critique and yeah yeah and
made sure to fix it I would imagine I
mean still got that neck Gina but
whatever right
hey editors for Trump if you're
listening next time just delete it all
just delete all of it it's not helping
like this is not helping because people
like that it's kind of helping me right
right it is funny it is one of your [__]
watch keep watching it gets funnier it
gets more hilarious good information and
fake news stories
to dishonest journalists of which are
many to perpetrate the Russia hoax and
that's what it was turned out it was a
total hoax it was all
misinformation it was all a horrible
thing that I I'm still waiting for the
question are you did you catch one yet
nope uh we're about a minute into him
saying there's a question and I haven't
got a question this is a really long
question it's a really long one uh this
is like in school when a teacher calls
on you and then you're like well so
you're just trying to run the clock
Before the bill yeah you're like all
right I got three minutes left so in the
chapter that you're asking about that
the question about whether
it it would can you repeat the question
for me
oh my God this chucklehead let's keep
let's keep going at the lights by the
way the reason again the reason why he's
saying uh the Russia was proved as a
hoax is because right now as we speak
Jack Smith is proving that it's not a
hoax
um and and and also the federal court
system and federal prosecutors are
proving that it's not a hoax in this uh
mcgongo what's his name this [__] FBI
guy
mcgaggle mcgagle Google
mechanical mechanical
mechanical not to be not to be confused
with uh McGonagall
from Harry Potter oh okay well I thought
it was like Magoo right you remember
Magoo Mister yeah I feel like calling
McGonagall Magoo is it offending Mr
Magoo I feel like it could be a fan Mr
Magoo yeah probably I mean at this
mcgonago character he was in the FBI he
was assigned a counterintelligence and
and the thing is right before the 2016
election he he he said there is no
collusion we're good to go no collusion
and then and then get this get this
he was the one who who helped
um Rosenstein take counterintelligence
off the table for the Mueller
investigation again which oh man uh
unbeknownst to anyone else this
McGonagall character was receiving
payments uh and laundering money for um
how what's that Russians oh yeah kind of
wait so you're telling me the guy that
was in the FBI was actually helping
Trump Oh you mean he he's the Deep State
yeah that's oh he's the swamp right kind
of funny okay okay kind of funny deep
[__] state is what uh what we should
call it over there let's let's let's
keep listening to How Russia isn't a
hoax and he's projecting that they are
investigating it probably because he
stole documents to cover it up that
would be my guess Gabe Sanchez is that
the reason why he's freaking out about
the Russia hoax again is because he
stole documents to cover that up and
they got those documents but let's keep
going it was given to the people of our
country
illegally by a fake press and a corrupt
press and by corrupt politicians
why did numerous FBI ncia analysts go
out
and purchase professional liability
insurance the day the fake steel dossier
was first published
why did Secret Service go and get
personal attorneys after they were
requested by the January 6 committee to
come in and present cell phone records
so Gabe Sanchez we have our first
question we are now a minute and a half
okay it took a minute and a half and the
question was why did FBI agents and CIA
agents buy liability insurance the day
that the Steele dossier was released
that's um that's that's his his first
reliability insurance from Prudential
State Farm Geico no no more nope deep
deep State Co is whatever oh deep state
code deep state code they sell like
don't you know this I mean it's in your
Soro santifa packet I haven't read
through the whole thing oh okay you
didn't make it I can't read
I don't know how to read apparently I
can barely do math well it's it is CRT
and yeah they are Banning classroom
libraries to teach children to read so
it's not surprising that you're a little
behind here yeah but we are at the first
question folks he wanted questions to be
asked and this is the question on every
American's mind let me tell you
something every American is concerned
out there that someone in a profession
would buy professional liability
insurance for their profession which
happens all the time did you know Gabe
Sanchez that almost every single law
enforcement officer in every single law
enforcement agency has professional
liability insurance did you know that
you know and you know what's funny about
this is he he's saying he's saying that
they bought professional liability
insurance
and they're in law enforcement it's
almost like he doesn't back the blue
anymore when he starts talking about
none of them ever did right because
here's the thing when if Jim Jordan's
dumbass asked this question to someone
who knows anything about this it's not
going to take more than 30 seconds for
that person to stuff Jim Jordan and this
question right into the right into the
[__] trash can into the garbage I
mean it really isn't it's ridiculous to
think that someone in the law enforce
enforcement profession in this country
doesn't have liability insurance almost
every real profession does attorneys
insurance agents uh real estate agents
anyone who has registered with the
government for a license to operate as a
business typically typically as some
sort of liability insurance especially
if you're a professional meaning you're
providing Services
um and again all law enforcement
agencies and and all law enforcement
officers rather you're the the Beat cop
in a local town or you're the FBI agent
who's investigating I don't know uh a
supposed billionaire in Russia's
collusion to steal the 2016 election
I don't know maybe just maybe but let's
just maybe let's go on let's see if
there's another question I'm I'm dying
to know because they knew it was fake
and they knew that sometimes there'd be
a guy like Trump that wants to go after
them have any fake news channels I loved
a guy like Trump you go after them and
he he takes a big hard you know yeah
yeah no most people most people who do
that there's a loogie that happens
afterwards no it doesn't for him it's
almost like it's almost like all that
[__] Adderall and [__] is just
completely just tore it tore a hole
through all right there's no sinuses
left for this dude I mean we've seen you
know when he was doing uh when he was
doing the
um I'm gonna keep it real close right
now when he was doing the uh
the debates he would be like
like all those things while he was crazy
wasn't there someone who cut that
together probably it was probably a
bunch of like
you know probably a bunch of stuff that
like when he was creepily stalking
Hillary Clinton during the debates right
he's like
no it just a bunch of you know it goes
back to the editor listen if you're
listening as the editor because you
might have been here last time when Gabe
Sanchez was talking about the color
saturation problem that you guys are
having there are definitely ways to
reduce the sound he's making right right
you guys can edit sound on the video as
well you can go through and you can heal
certain parts of your right audio
timeline but right hey you know who's
counting I'm okay not them let's see if
we got another question coming up here
I'm really dying to know what questions
Jim Jordan's gonna ask the clouds all
right I don't know who's gonna ask these
questions I have no idea it's been paid
or compensated by U.S government
agencies directly or indirectly for
their role in spreading domestic
disinformation like the FBI did with
Twitter paid them three million six
hundred thousand dollars so far that we
know of so there it is there's the claim
that Twitter that Twitter was
compensated for their employees work for
directives that the government needed
um for counterintelligence and and it's
it's so ridiculous you need to tell me
that a company was compensated for doing
additional work that was outside the
purview of what the company normally
does on day to day it's that's like when
like when you're telling me that like
when a when an employee
or a department is in charge of
moderating or or looking through normal
conversations just for regular stuff
right unprompted they see something they
report it but when an agency comes in
and says hey we actually need part of
your team to work with us on the
specific project meaning that terrorism
they didn't want to they were yes you're
telling me that because those people
couldn't do their normal job
that a companies or an agency or an
organization said hey for the time that
we are
um
you know distracting your employees from
their normal job we're gonna compensate
them uh for the time to actually do the
things that we're asking you to do
we are a company hiring you as a client
so we will pay you it's almost like
that's how business works right it's
funny uh you know I can't wait because I
see the the road that's happening here
Gabe Sanchez I hope because
um these committees are going to be
formed these special committees to
investigate I I hope
Katie Porter's whiteboard makes it on
one of these [__] committees I really
do and here's what I also hope is that
Jim Jordan and these idiots decide that
the Twitter files is something they want
to bring into public hearings because
the person that is going to have to come
testify
um with these Twitter files is Elon Musk
himself yeah which is go oh my God you
talk you talk about this [__] up
against like Katie Porter are you
[__] [__] me Elon Musk wouldn't have
a [__] prayer against Katie Porter
when she explains to him with her
[__] whiteboard and Elon Musk has to
sit there at the table and say Well yeah
if if the government forced me to do
work that was outside of our company's
purview I wouldn't want them to
compensate me and my employees I
shouldn't have to pay my employees maybe
like Elon has done this before how oh my
what are you saying are you saying are
you saying that is a possibility
that the the the Takeover of Twitter has
already done this since this has
happened or what are you saying there
specifically I'm not saying that it's
already happened I'm saying that
previous companies like uh Tesla or not
Tesla but like uh SpaceX or starlink or
um they take government money don't they
yeah oh man they're built they're built
on government money and look it's
whether or not it's a direct payment or
a subsidy
um you're taking money from a government
they're hiring you as a contractor as a
client and the typical way that business
works and for all these Republicans that
are like oh no why was a government
agency paying a private company the same
reason that you would pay a private
company that you contract work from hey
look can you go through and spend your
time and your age and your and your
company's resources and your Gathering
up us some evidence to give us
information because you it's like look
what would you rather do because these
are the options right a company says or
an agency or government agency says hey
we want access to your stuff and then
that that company says no we're not
giving you a back door in you know and
you can go look at prism and other
things that have been revealed about
that there was there was a big lawsuit
between the FBI and apple during the San
Bernardino shootings give us access to
the phone they're like that's not how we
work we won't do that for you and so
that you know took a stance there but
it's the same reason if a private
company was asked by a government agency
hey give us back end backdoor access to
go look through and search this stuff
you're like whoa I don't know whether
you're gonna like go outside your
purview right and violate people's uh
rights right
so then instead the company says all
right well we could be forced ultimately
by a judge to do this so we'll just
cooperate and we will work with you so
they said we will go through our
employees Twitter employees will go
through scan and work with you guys to
figure out what should be we should be
looking for so that we are able to
identify and flag that and then report
back to you on whether we find something
that's valid or we don't find something
that's valid but you gotta pay for it
but you gotta pay it forward totally
because at that point then you're like
if I have less people and less resources
allocated to do anything that I normally
do then we won't be able to do our job
effectively so if you're going to ask us
to give you resources time and people
then you have to compensate us you have
to give us money but again Republicans
are like oh no they shouldn't have paid
it should have been done for free can
you imagine can you imagine a true
social had to do this for the government
how much they would ask for how much
money they would ask for and I almost
feel how much money because they don't
make any right I almost bet I almost bet
that that's an actual real thing that
has already happened that they've had
that that the government has had to pay
them for some sort of contract work on
their own platform that the government
needed information for I'm almost
certain that that's probably happened
again this is all bone-ended [__] they
take something and they make it what
it's not right and it's not easy to
track this stuff down of what it
actually is you just I don't know use
like rational thought logic
um you know A and B like dot to DOT type
stuff really simple stuff it's not hard
I mean you just color within the lines
you you [__] idiots don't eat the
crowns color within the lines okay okay
I love the Crayons which color is your
favorite flavor uh blue blue okay that
specific blue or just any of them nah
just like like a royal blue maybe so
like the blue sock in the in the Crayola
94 right yeah yeah that's exactly that's
the one you were eating yeah the
original the OG right so you didn't you
had all the other colors blue gone that
was it does your [__] turn blue when you
eat the blue grounds I don't know it
does I mean just chunks oh okay okay
good
let's see if there's another question
from Grandpa here that he's directing
Jim Jordan to ask can you imagine being
Jim Jordan he's like okay I got my
notepad out these are the questions I'm
supposed to ask and he's like what the
what okay I got one question out of that
whole thing I'm almost halfway through
this video and there's been one one
question and it's and I know the answer
too and I definitely don't want to ask
that question
um because that one I'll get my ass
handed to me if I ask someone who knows
that question so let's let's continue
the FBI paid think of this to Twitter
over three million dollars oh my God and
the purpose was to get it wrong to do
bad things to our country who
orchestrated the FBI's repeated
operations to interfere in domestic
politics in the final weeks of multiple
U.S election seasons
and specifically and most importantly
in the presidential election of 2020
what the FBI did was suppress anything
bad about almost a question he was
almost there he almost asked a question
when you think he's about to right
yeah no he totally walks all over the
question mark like just shits all over
it like he shits his diapers I mean the
only question I see him asking is what
is a question you know
that is the real question yeah what is
you know
having thought about this they produced
this five minute piece of content this
probably has I don't know how many hours
of Manpower trying to [__] get this
clip out on fraud social for him of
where he's ranting about this or
whatever he's doing because he's
terrified the Jack Smith got documents
down at Mar-A-Lago that's going to prove
that there was collusion with Russia and
he's trying to divert everyone's
attention by by getting Jim Jordan to
maybe ask the questions if Jim Jordan
can figure out what the [__] the
questions are that he's trying to that
he's trying to ask but you would think
that someone wrote this [__] down like
someone sat down with him like okay
let's bullet point this for a second
let's just let's get some bullet points
and then let's go through the questions
and let's write some questions down and
then let's do cue cards like really
simple or we can do like a teleprompter
he's not very good at reading so maybe
like cue cards to remind him of the
question or something wait you cards
yeah uh-oh cue cards do some dematria
with that I don't know
um is it Dimitri is that what is that
the word am I using that correctly
that's right yeah we're gonna add where
you add numbers
I don't [__] I don't know let's let's
listen to the Q a or maybe he'll tell us
about Biden and go all out
put it all out there if it was anything
at all bad about Trump and if there
wasn't anything bad we'll make it up
what that was is a rigged election just
by itself
what was the role of federal agents and
informants and pressing the crowd toward
the capital
on January 6. there's a question oh my
God hey you know what it's almost like
Congress
in the last two years had a special
select committee that answered that
question it's almost like they did 10
hearings
to answer that question that he just
asked in that in that that's weird yeah
it's really weird he finally comes up
with another question and it's a
question that has already been answered
time and time again give improved given
evidence
and he asked why does he want Jim Jordan
to ask this question I'm not really sure
about how why the the violence director
what what are you talking about man we
know why the we know why the mob of
[__] toothless idiots went up to the
[__] capital and committed violence
and Ashley Babbitt got shot in the face
and and police officers got killed we
know why we know why they wanted to hang
Mike Pence we know why these are not
questions that we don't know the answers
to your the answers right in front of
our face you you [__] vile Trader
okay let's let's continue here
and who is raps tell me about raps where
does he come from I think we know there
it is that's a question there's a
question that was like the quickest
question he's got so far you know you
know what I I think that same committee
that answered the last question
I think they actually had a guy named
Ray Epps come in and testify under oath
and they answered the question of who is
raps and they were like this is just
some [__] moglodyte this is very
absent you're just just a dude he's just
a he's a [__] dude who showed up and
he's mad because Facebook told them to
be mad what what why why why why would
Jim Jordan asking that question have
anything why would that be
groundbreaking if they asked that
question does he think the answer to
that question is going to be anything
but what has already been answered that
Ray Epps is just some [__] schlob
that that came to the Capitol to do what
he said for him to do
was it's going to be wild remember and
we're gonna take we're gonna take our
country back
and you can't silence our voices or
something part of me really thinks that
he should have gone to the Capitol I
honestly just think that oh the Secret
Service should have let him go to the
Capitol and I would have loved to see
this little cuck try to fight his way
against the cops and get hit in the
[__] head by his own people get
knocked the [__] out fall down the steps
like an old man that he is and then in
just in a weak fashion try to act like
oh oh yeah I'm the victim like he's some
kind of tough guy look at the face he's
making here does that look like I really
got a [__]
[Music]
oh it's prairie dogging oh
oh the guy's pinching a loaf here in his
time he's like Are we almost done yet
hurry hurry you're like if you ask the
questions faster
get to the [__] point man he's like
oh God uh Ray Epps who's right up I
don't know
this is too easy it's way way too easy
yeah it's you can't make this [__] up uh
by the way I'm gonna show you another uh
Eric chihuahua come out with a
commercial oh my god oh it's great it's
[__] hilarious let's let's continue
watching uh poopy pants here
um because we're gonna discover who Ray
Epps is I'm sure I mean you know where
he came from if we know where he came
from why the [__] do we gotta ask the
question I don't understand you said it
came from who is Ray Epps raps we know
where who he is
why do you have to ask these questions
okay let's let's see if there's another
question that they're gonna they're
gonna ask
in addition the committee needs to do a
full review of fisa warrants and any
abuse of confidential government
databases
to conduct political spying on American
citizens they spied on American citizens
illegally
and they got illegal approvals they
Trump did that same thing
right by lying to judges the judges
should be very upset but they don't okay
okay I'm just I'm just I'm just I'm just
gonna go out on a limb here and say that
some of the documents that they that
they got at Mar-A-Lago
um show the actual intelligence that
they collected by spying illegally on
yeah he's an American he was that he was
creating crime he was committing crime
when they he was trying to spy on
reporters and journalists no they're not
listen reporters and journalists are not
American citizens that's not a thing
they're the enemies they're the enemies
they're enemies in the states I mean
they're not I mean they're not good at
their jobs but I don't I don't know if
they're Traders they're just not good at
their jobs in most cases they're enemy
in the state if they don't like you
they're not real people
AI robots
we all know who he is we all know where
he came from what the [__] yeah
we should also get a full report on any
domestic surveillance of Maga supporters
that has taken place under Biden
or Obama and the radical left
Joe Biden is presiding over the most
corrupt Administration in American
history
so he's moved on from the questions now
he's now we just want full reports of
[__] that doesn't exist
just yeah he's like hey all that stuff
that doesn't exist let's do a report on
it that way we can act like it's
official and [__] who's the boogeyman I
don't know we're gonna do report who's
the boogeyman the boogeyman we all know
where he came from who he is but who is
he I don't know I don't know it's gonna
be good I'll tell you it's not so good
he's a guy he's a new bed maybe a new
closet no no he's spying on you can you
imagine watching this and thinking oh
yeah this is oh yeah baby get getting
getting the old jack off going on with
this like what the [__] is wrong with
you people I really think this guy is
I'm sure that the person who uh the
intern that is filming this
is
my [__] brains out he's like I'm
gonna tell you and he's like oh my God
how many we've done this line like 10
times why can't he get it I feel like
there's also someone up that's got huge
[__] snlq cards where they're just
like because that's actually how they do
SNL they do old school cue cards that
are changed literally minutes before if
they need to to cut a sketch change a
sketch whatever
but the idea that you've got this I mean
I've got a I've got a reflection board
over that's by me right now when I film
what was that that's like four uh it's
like three by four kind of shape but
that's the size of the here
this is
I'll show it's a it's a
I got this thing right here right yeah
it's just it's just a it's like a
styrofoam right you know reflection but
this is the thing if it blocks the
screen because it's so big but that's
that's what that's what the
[__] are holding that's what
they're holding when they do and they're
kind of looking at it and they're like
where's he at I don't know where he is
right like that's probably why it's so
discombobulated because they're not he's
not going through the cue cards he'll
like say the cute card and then he goes
on and Rambles on and on and shitty once
ahead and they're like that's that's
what the [__] are you looking at each
other and like I don't know dude and
he's like Nuke your car they're like
dude there was a question and it was two
lines long but you went on some [__]
tangent about uh the uh just like all
this [__] maybe that's why we didn't get
that many questions because they had to
skip them because they were just like
well just throw that one out I mean he's
not even he's not even paying attention
they're just like I I just don't [__] it
we're going to lunch just keep it
rolling I'll come back and I'll edit
just let him just yeah we'll cut that
[__] together just and they're like they
go to lunch they go have they have their
meal they go have a couple drinks you
know they come back at five he's still
[__] going
he's [__] sweating you know he's
melting but look at him he's he's having
a tough time here
he's having a tough time she's really
trying to hold in that shite oh you know
because he doesn't want to have to stop
again for another diaper
if he stops the bowels go you know right
so he's gotta keep it moving that's what
the breathing is
like he's doing [__] Lamaze class
like all right preaching he's preaching
oh God I knew this video would be great
content today and we could laugh at this
because this is so [__] hilarious and
I didn't even watch it I just listened
to it I shut the phone down and I was
listening to it while I was doing
something else because I knew I I needed
to know what the [__] he said if it was
worth watching and it's been worth it
and we're gonna get to some news here I
know people are getting antsy about some
of the news that's going on but trust me
we can't stop now we have to finish well
we gotta see how he finishes I mean I
don't we don't want to see how he
finishes well oh you oh you want to see
how he finishes we'll see how he wraps
this uh not how he wraps this thing okay
you know what I'm just gonna stop
talking let's go
their weaponization of law enforcement
intelligence agencies and the Deep state
is very in fact deep seated
the greatest threat American freedom in
Generations has seen
more projection we just talked about the
[__] FBI McGonagall who is deep State
who is actually deep State who was
federal law enforcement who is using his
influence to make sure that this guy
would not be caught in the [__]
collusion with Russia and he was paid by
Dara posca to possibly do it we're going
to find that out in [__] open court
why he was why McGonagall was paid what
he was paid for because there's
something that dear posca paid him for
and this is all ridiculous that somehow
they're weaponizing the FBI to go after
Maga listen they're [__] domestic
terrorists these people are threatening
to kill other people they're going into
politicians home and smashing their
spouses in with hammers you dumb
[__] yeah of course that law
enforcement agencies are doing what they
do trying to prevent crime and domestic
terrorism this is so [__] dumb that
we have to sit here and listen to this
chucklehead project
what that what he wants to have happen
when when it's the Republican party that
has continued to stoke this stochastic
terrorism [__]
um on marginalized communities and other
politicians it's [__] ridiculous but
you know we even have Pena Pena I mean
there's a good example of a manga
terrorist yep who who couldn't stand
that he lost a [__] election and his
mind was [__] and deluded by Q Anon so
he became a domestic terrorist and he
got caught with law enforcement and they
[__] arrested him and charged him
he's gonna go to prison for it you
[__] fool once
hell finish her up and their collusion
with the fake news media is absolutely
atrocious this committee is a vital
chance to bring it all to light
begin to heal our divisions and save our
Beloved Country
I want to thank you for listening but
it's a big problem we have to do
something for it I also want to pay my
respect to James Comer
and Jim Jordan for the incredible job
they're doing
for the work they're doing and for
the love they have for our country thank
you both
oh yeah thank you Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan for bringing things to
light because that is definitely what
Jim Jordan is known for Gabe Sanchez is
making sure when something bad happens
within his realm of his power of
bringing it to light that Jim Jordan
definitely he definitely does not cover
up sexual abuse or anything like that
yeah
it does not do that and when Jake Tapper
asks James Comer uh hey are you gonna
call this uh hypocrisy out here and he
goes no no Donald Trump did uh way less
of a Bad Thing than Joe Biden Joe Biden
is the Real Enemy and the real villain
here and we should not be uh
investigating Trump the same way we
should be looking at him less than Biden
we should be looking in a Biden and
impeaching him
yeah it's crazy the lack of calling out
your look if you're gonna have all
things equal here and you want special
counsels for anyone who had classified
documents let's [__] run the bill
baby let's do it yep Senators
Congressman let's let's do this [__]
let's do the [__] now there's some news
um in a um
um what is this news about that we're
and we're going to
um
is this about the police
huh are you talking about the cops yeah
yeah what's the news here do you have a
link for this
um
because there's five cops charged in um
uh recently I just don't want to get it
wrong yeah yeah I want to make sure I
get this story correct
I don't want to be spreading
uh misinformation or getting again
getting the facts wrong and we operate
in truth here and as true as we can get
it you know it is the [__] internet
yeah so this is breaking news Tyree
Nichols case there's been five police
officers being charged is that it uh do
we know do we know uh why you're giving
me a link here do we know what the um
the charges that they brought against
these officers are uh second-degree
murder okay so
um I'm finding five cops and uh 50
Shades as it here he says um here I'll
bring it up okay and I'm sure 50s is uh
got this going it's about 15 minutes ago
he posted five caps in Tennessee who
were fired for beating a 29 year old man
to death during a traffic stop I've been
charged in the second degree murder
aggravated assault kidnapping according
to Shelby County Jail Dr Nichols died in
the hospital a few days later after the
assault
um and so that looks like what is going
to happen
um and again this is in Memphis
uh in the beating death of Tyree Nichols
and the five officers
uh here
um here are pictures of these five
officers uh Phillip has it here all five
officers including involved excuse me in
the brutal beating death of diary
Nichols have been indicted so these five
officers have been indicted
on second degree murder charges can't
wait to hear how Republicans want to
spin this oh boy
and well I mean
it's it's going to be the same old
stupid [__] lies I mean this is the
party of Santos and Trump
I mean it lies it's just going to be
lies all around so
um so moving forward in that I want to
go back now to
um
this swalwell yeah [__] and like this
swallow commercial
um
this is a great commercial by the way oh
yeah
it's a great production uh when I saw it
I was like
is this did Sanchez do this
um here is um it's just it is it's
pretty close it's pretty close it's
pretty close to some past things I've
done did you did they consult with you
at all yeah full disclosure oh well they
must have just copied they aren't the
Lincoln project but you know maybe yeah
you know I'll take it as flattery right
let's let's uh let's watch were you
arrested trying to overthrow the
government on January 6th are you facing
sleepless nights worried the rule of law
will catch up to you the lawyers at
Insurrection LLC are standing by to take
your call we will fight for your right
to commit treason without accountability
at Insurrection LLC we understand it's
your right to obstruct Justice and plots
Edition and for a limited time only if
you call Insurrection LLC in the next 15
minutes we'll include a free gas stove
were you arrested trying to over okay
okay and
it's [__] beautiful that's perfect
that's perfect
um so I want to go and since we're
talking about Insurrection and the
reason why Donald Trump was let off the
hook are well he's he's recently got his
Facebook account back
um from Facebook he appealed he was
begging he was he was debating uh suing
them oh really I thought he already sued
him did he lose that lawsuit I mean
where are we at uh no this was a this is
recent because they're like we're gonna
sue you guys if you don't give me back
my Facebook account you know and that's
I that's me being a lawyer for Trump oh
okay yeah well I mean that's about that
that's about as much lawyering as yeah
they're like he should be back on
Facebook because he deserves it and he
was a president and then Trump's like
Facebook is the best place better than
two social don't tell my people what is
Facebook and who is Reyes we all know
who they are Facebook and raps are
brothers
um
so the ACLU decided to chime in on this
issue of Facebook deciding to let Trump
back on and again folks uh here's my
opinion I'm of the and as I tweeted it
and I said I'm of the opinion that
sunlight will disinfect that vile Trader
but you might want to figure out what it
what it is and what it is not protective
speech ACLU because here's their tweet
it says this is the right call like it
or not president Trump is one of the
country's leading political figures and
the public has a strong interest in
hearing his speech no that that is not
because when when you say
that the public
has a strong interest in hearing his
speech you're making a case for
protected speech they already had the
chance
to hear his speech they just have to
type in a different URL right that that
does not infringe the the the idea that
a person has to go search for his speech
on a different URL is somehow him not
being protected with his speech is
[__] mind-blowing you know I think I
believe that the ACL the ACLU it didn't
think about this for more than a half a
second because I feel you should
probably go help Republicans try to
defend Newsmax being on DirecTV because
that's the exact same argument right
here's the thing it's not like there's a
mass conspiracy in in collaboration with
a bunch of different private entities
that say hey we're gonna silence the
speech of this individual or this group
by removing them from all of our
platforms so they are completely
de-platformed and again they could all
decide to do that because they are
private companies it's not like the
government has a state
and the ACLU is making that case that
the government is the ones making sure
that the public has the ability to have
for in the strong interest of hearing
his speech they can already we just did
it we just did it Gabe Sanchez on our
show I show I mean
if you call it speech it's kind of just
like rambling yeah I mean it's just like
a word sound right right I mean you know
if you put it in a video it sounds
better I don't know no but the point is
this is that you just have to type in a
different URL because this is not this
is not as if this is public broadcasting
right yeah like this is not network
television that we're talking about
these are private websites that a person
has to have access to the internet for
and they have to see it they have to
have internet access and they have to
type in a URL wait wait hold on backup
Backup backup right I was not on Twitter
and not on Facebook
how would I find his stuff that's you
know that's a good point and maybe maybe
what the ACLU is saying is they're going
to force you to have a Facebook account
so that you have to go read it it's
really stupid [__] yeah it's dumb stuff
I've tried to explain this before with
the example of a Walmart you have the
right with your speech to protest
Walmart you can say all kinds of crazy
[__] that you want to say about Walmart
you can't spray paint it on the side of
their building you do not have the right
in your speech to spray paint or stand
outside their front doors you cannot
stand outside their front doors or
inside their inside their store and and
and and protest them that is not your
right that's that that that is not
speech that is protected by the
government for you your speech is
protected off their property
and you can say what you want you can
write it in the newspaper as long as the
newspaper will publish it
the newspaper doesn't even have the
doesn't have the mandate to publish it
if they're like well this is just a
crazy [__] word salad from someone
who looks like they believe in Q Anon
and they're saying crazy [__] about
Walmart We're Not Gonna improve this
they can do that they can do that it but
it is not your right to force again the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you do not have
the ability to force a social media
platform to let you back on and frankly
the [__] that they're saying about the
Twitter files and oh my God the
government made Twitter do all this and
they made them make [__] up and blah
blah blah that is literally right now
what Jim Jordan Comer and the
Republicans in the house are going to
try and do they are going to try to
force social media platforms
to bend to their will and let whoever
they want and whatever Nazis they want
on their platforms and these social
media platforms are getting like no
we're not letting that hateful [__]
dribble on our platforms and Republicans
you have to because they're conservative
no they're Nazis it's hate speech we do
not have to let that on our [__]
platform we own it if you want to own it
buy it from us
buy it buy it and then the government
can run it yeah if that's what you want
which again you don't want because you
don't want big government and you want
things to be deregulated so again you
can have both ways you can't have it
where you know it it helps you this way
and then when it hurts you you say no it
doesn't count we we don't talk about
that right
that's the that's the way that they want
it and that's the way that they believe
Free Speech works and their ex you know
access to free speech and their rights
the First Amendment you know and
yeah I also because I got a couple
stories that I want to get yeah so I
don't mean to walk on that no it's fine
um uh one thing that Rachel bittickoff
are pointing out the today and I I
retweeted it now again I I'm not going
to go through the poll but the point is
is that it's the numbers are showing
that two out of three Americans are
concerned that the House GOP is going to
cut their Medicare and Social Security I
wonder why that could be I wonder if
it's that they said that that's what
they wanted to do and they keep saying
that's what they want to do I wonder if
that's why people are [__] concerned
about it but Rachel points out a great
Point here no matter what the numbers
are what the polling is people are going
to be concerned when Republicans say out
loud we want to take away your Medicare
and your Social Security they're going
to get worried but what you have to do
is wedge Republicans stealing they're so
your Social Security and your Medicare
everywhere you have to wedge it you have
to take the issue and you have to wedge
it and how you wedge it is you wedge it
between their constituents and the
politicians and you wed wedge the
politicians make them make them ask them
questions but more than any anything
wedge their constituents against them
that's the most important thing because
their constituents are going to be
concerned about losing their Medicare
and their social security
um there's a Mac ant Story and there's
not a lot of information on this but
angry staffer actually posted something
earlier about this I don't know people
have heard this there's allegations out
there that Matt gants possibly has had
an affair with one of his male staffers
I guess which I don't give a [__] if
Matt Getz as bisexual or gay I don't
give a [__] whatever floats his boat and
also he's not underage that's all I
guess well there's also that and then
there's his uh not actually adopted son
Nester yes which he's been you know he's
had since Nestor was a teenager uh oh
a little weird uh Angry Stamper says
here I wondered uh about this live uh
it's even more interesting in the light
of new Matt gatz rumors that's not a
friendly shoulder pet
um if you remember when Matt Getz was
trying to uh defy Kevin McCarthy his
speakership on the 14th vote when they
didn't have the votes and they had to go
to a 15th vote for him to get speaker
um he was sitting there to find they
were trying to get him off the floor to
negotiate and um they were threatening
him is what this is here this is a
threat he's leaning in he's whispering
to him hey we got the dirt remember the
dirt that we got on you remember how we
treated Madison Gotham with the cocaine
sex orgies you remember that you
remember that uh don't worry he said
whatever he said and then he said okay
and it was one of those moments where
it's like look I don't care if you you
vote for McCarthy or you vote present do
one of them you know what's funny
after this happened is when Kevin
McCarthy became speaker
seems I don't know just saying people
got [__] on everybody in there right I
don't know no one is safe in that house
who who knows if those two things have
anything to do with each other oink yeah
they absolutely do
um so another story that I want to go to
um Missouri the Missouri governor
um is let's see is that the yeah okay so
the Missouri governor is attacking uh
drag performances as they are everywhere
in these [__] bigoted ass States
including mine
um but Andrew's story uh he's he's in
the Missouri house Dems
um posted a video from a legislator
session this is [__] beautiful and
um folks spread this video around we
need to get this video out to more
people to understand uh and maybe maybe
it will Enlighten people of what is
important and what is not [__]
important for our legislators to be
doing I'm not just talking about the
[__] that the House of
Representatives because this is
happening all around in the [__]
State ledgers these [__] scumbags are
trying to take away people's [__]
Liberties but this clip here
um is beautiful that um and Andrew's
story uh post you comment at the Queens
you best not miss with so much areas
needing legislators focused the Missouri
gop's priorities are attacking trans
children and drag shows and here is a
drag drag queen uh giving handing them
their ass this is great and this again
is the exact way to handle these
scumbags if you didn't know and I hope
you do because it's kind of your job
Missouri ranks 26th in education 49th in
school funding
great job there
39th in economic growth we have
witnessed Early Education enrollment for
pre-k dropping by 300 000 kids teachers
are quitting in Mass we are literally
now having school four days a week
after school programs are also
struggling to provide for students for
our economy
we've seen point two percent growth
okay that is Missouri's economy so
Missouri's economy which is a red state
which Gabe Sanchez you know that when
when a red States when Republicans Run
Red States oh it's like they're the
richest States in no yeah actually it's
the opposite it's the opposite of that
they actually are broke as far growth
for years right yeah and even with the
high GDP that they brag about that
happened under whatever they still can't
have growth in these states and the
reason why is because they're so [__]
focused on [__] that doesn't matter and
watch watch how she ramps it up in a bow
over five years
that's not a good success rate folks
this is a clear indicator that
businesses and the workforce are not
investing in or coming to Missouri
because they view our state as a land in
which people cannot achieve the American
dream I've got a whole lot of other
things to tell you about economic growth
but I don't think we're going to solve
that today what I do want to address is
who I am where I'm from what I do and
what realistically happens at these
shows now you all said there's only one
person who had never seen a drag show so
we're going to talk in a vernacular that
you would understand so I have been
performing for 15 years of my life my
knees probably been performing for 47
years but in that time I've been able to
do a lot of incredible things I have
been a queen of Pride not only in St
Louis and Joplin and also in Springfield
I have represented our America system if
you don't know what that is it's been
around for 49 years so I'm sorry
representative Baker and Boyd drag's
been here a lot longer than you knew
damn
like hey look this isn't new [__] you
[__] bigots you just picked this out
because you need a distraction of how
bad you are and how horrible you are at
your [__] jobs and not only that
you're trying to get all these [__]
troll farms and if you didn't know in
participation
um with with this the test stochastic
terrorism of trying to demonize a
marginalized Community like the lgbtq
community which the country is behind
and they have their support and we are
allies of them so stop your nonsense
um and she does it so well by pointing
out that they are so horrible on the
economy
um there's one more video that I saw
this morning that I want to play and
this is we watched these during last
summer uh when they overturned Roe v
Wade oh yeah okay oh this is hilarious
um this is Roe versus Bros let's watch
did her family talk to you about sex ed
my dad was saying something about lying
with a woman and that's when you put
your seed inside of her we're her the
marsh for life for another episode of
Roe v Rose the game show where we find
out how much men know about women's
bodies can you get pregnant if you pull
out before ejaculating no
gotcha how long does sperm live in the
vagina
[Music]
a couple hours I think oldly nine months
eight months
six no hints I'm gonna go two minutes
yeah two minutes or else she's pregnant
doesn't it live in there the whole time
two minutes and forever
I just don't know much about women's
bodies how much does it cost to deliver
a baby without insurance
can you get pregnant if you pull out
before ejaculating
I guess it depends on where things land
after that how many ovaries does a woman
have in her lifetime
I don't know at least like five uh let's
go eight what made you say eight
it's my lucky number do you think you're
lucky right now
probably not did you have sex ed in
school yes do you have sex at in school
yes yeah I had sex out in school were
those answers in mind clearly there's
more work to be done send this to a
friend who needs to know more about
women's bodies
so just send it to all men like you know
all over much because I mean at least
that one at least that one guy was like
look I don't okay
I want to control them but I have no
idea what the [__] yeah he's like you
know look I don't know I don't know how
to count ovaries I can't tell you the
time I can't tell you the duration I
can't tell you this I can't tell you
that
but at least you know at least one of
them's honest yo Bros your family talk
to you about sex yo Bros yo yo you don't
know [__] about women's bodies stay the
[__] out of the conversation it's not a
conversation you don't try to control
them don't try to right you know it's
you got you you [__] Republicans have
this weird Obsession this fixation with
candy gender genitalia and Mr Potato
Head penis and Dr Seuss books and this
and that their obsession is deeply
rooted in transphobia and their desire
to uh control other people's genitalia
okay and women are a number one example
someone points this out uh P2 on YouTube
says I wish she'd asked those questions
to Congress I wish or get Congress to
ask those questions maybe or understand
those questions might be important when
they're I don't know making decisions
about things they don't know anything
about uh speaking of questions to be
asked by Congress let's let's do the
most important question of the day folks
from the Cheeto dusk unitard before we
leave let's let's listen to a one more
time the most important question that is
on everyone's mind in America this is
the number one story and the number one
question that is rocking people's minds
on January 6. and who is raps tell me
about raps where does he come from I
think we know that's it that's it that's
the question who is Rhea
who is he I think we know I don't know
why you're asking a question if you know
what the question is I think we do is
the goddamn reps he comes from a place I
don't know oh my God just think about it
use your head think about it
thanks for sticking around today through
the um the the true social dive that we
made we can't wait for uh Donald Trump
to make his way back to Facebook and
Twitter at least I can I am ready I'm
ready for this I'm ready to drag him
every single day all day and I hope you
are too you have to fight with democracy
and do that here on the Tony Michaels
podcast make sure to subscribe on
YouTube we'll give you the national
narrative the national messaging to push
forward we're trying to get to 20 000 so
subscribe to the YouTube channel now if
you're on YouTube you're not described
what the hell are you doing what are you
doing put the button hit the button hit
the name button and if you're not on
YouTube
do what the Deep State wants you to do
and protect your speech type in a
different URL go to youtube.com search
the Tony Michaels podcast And subscribe
okay it's your protected speech right
and mine too as long as I don't piss off
YouTube and they take me off so it's not
protected oh boy oh boy there's a terms
of service who would have thunk it also
download every single episode on Apple's
Spotify Google we also have terms of
services there I don't know if they know
that as well but you know it happens it
happens it happens I want to thank
everyone who has joined patreon again
I'm gonna do some so I am trying to
figure this out I don't buy like roll
credits I do a special like a video that
I post somewhere for shout outs um for
patreon I'm figuring it out so I'll get
the shout outs out but shout out to
everyone who has joined patreon if you
want to support me on patreon you can go
to patreon.com Michaels or go to the
Tony michaels.com hit the patreon
and that little thing at the top and
thank you very much for your support oh
man grabbing up some great support do
you have a what was that coming out I do
here let me just uh I just put in the
chat there's a brand new what was that
that came out today it's about Tucker
Carlson Fox News and their obsession
with candy penises people whoo M Ms and
wieners okay so tomorrow let's make sure
let's make sure to play before bonehead
actually you know what I almost bet we
could play that in bonehead I would say
that there's probably gonna be some
Eminem type bonehead oh yeah in there so
um so tomorrow we'll play the what was
that but go watch it right now make sure
to give Gabe Sanchez support and go
watch and tomorrow we'll we'll maybe
we'll play part of it or how long is it
it's only seven minutes seven minutes
it's a short one why why wouldn't you
gonna go watch it a little quick you
know Seven Minutes in Heaven yeah well
tiny hands tiny M M's
all right everyone go check out what was
that thanks to all the the patrons who
have subscribed to the patreon don't
forget to subscribe to the YouTube
channel once again don't forget for
bonehead of the week that's right that's
right uh you go follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod you can vote on
Twitter at Tony Michael's pod and on the
YouTube Community tab
tomorrow's Friday so of course Friday's
bonehead of the week second hour ready
until tomorrow
same time same [__] place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon